من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان
ان بلاده كانت ولا تزال الاكثر التزاما
بالاتفاق النووي وتعمل الولايات المتحده
بانها غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار شجاع
بالعوده للاتفاق
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق النووي كانت ايران
وما تزال الاكثر التزاما الطرف الذي انسحب
منه هو ترامب والولايات المتحده على
الولايات المتحده الا تتبنى سلوكا مخادعا
وان تعود بدلا من ذلك الى الاتفاق وتنهج
نهجا في ظل الحكومه الجديده للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه قررنا مواصله الحوار
من اجل العوده الى الاتفاق واجرينا
مناقشات طويله للغايه في فيينا قالت
الولايات المتحده انها في مرحله التوصل
للاتفاق لكن الايرانيين يطالبون باكثر من
اللازم صراحه في السنوات القليله الماضيه
راينا ان المسؤولين الامريكيين غير قادرين
على اتخاذ قرار بسبب مشكلاتهم الداخليه
والضغوط التي يتعرضون لها